alright Part D to investigate the claim
that exposure to light overrides the
genetically controlled circadian rhythm
the researchers plan to repeat the
experiment with mutant mice lacking a
gene that controls the circadian rhythm
predict the observed activity pattern of
the mutant mice under l12 d12 conditions
and under DD continuous darkness
conditions that would support the claim
that light overrides the genetically
controlled circadian rhythm all right so
let me write this down so Part D so
under some mutant mice mutant mice under
so let me make two columns mutant mice
under l12 l12 d12 and then under
continuous continuous darkness what
would I expect what would I expect so
they predict the observed activity
pattern so the mutant mice they don't
have they they have some they're lacking
genes that control circadian rhythm but
under l12 d12 they don't need the
genetic circadian patterns genetically
influenced ones because they get the
ones from their environment the light
and the darkness they didn't they didn't
get this isn't a gene that somehow makes
them not sensitive to light so I would I
would assume under the l12 d12 they
would behave a they would have activity
pattern similar to non mutant mice
activity same as non mutant as non
mutant mutant mice non act or inactivity
in activity during l12 activity activity
during d12 that's what I would expect
that they'd still could react to the
light and the darkness the same way that
a non mutant mice would now what about
continuous darkness the non mutant mice
we said that they stay they went off of
a 24-hour cycle but they still had a
cycle where they were in active active
inactive active and it was less than 12
hours for each cycle but it was close to
those maybe 9 10 or 11 hours of activity
followed by 9 10 or 11 hours of
inactivity I would guess that a mutant
Mouse that has no that that doesn't have
some of these genes for circadian rhythm
well for them it's just going to be this
is going to be random it's just going to
be much more sporadic so much much more
sporadic sporadic activity activity
fewer fewer continuous continuous Yrsa
maybe less continuous periods or made a
shorter continuous periods shorter
continuous periods of activity and
inactivity
activity slash in activity all right now
let's look at Part II now so that was my
predictions with I would see four mutant
mice in either of these so now let's go
to Part II in nature mice are potential
prey from some for some predatory birds
that hunt during the day describe two
features of a model that represents how
the predator-prey relationship between
the birds and the mice may have resulted
in the evolution of the observed
activity pattern of mice well if the if
the birds hunt during the day if Birds
hunt during day a mouse is more likely
to be eaten by a bird if it's active
during the day Mouse then
then the mouse is more likely to be
eaten eaten if it is active during the
day if it is active during the day and
if it is I guess you could say that's
one that's one feature of our model that
you're just more likely to be eaten if
you're active when the birds are hunting
and then the second one is if you're
more likely to be eaten then you're less
likely to reproduce if actually I should
be a capital I if if the mouse is more
likely to be eaten by being active
during the day then it is less likely to
reproduce then it is less likely to
reproduce and if I were if I were taking
the AP test here I would try to put as
much context as possible because you're
not exactly sure how they're going to
the mark to mark this thing to grade
this thing so you can give more context
that therefore the mice that that are
active during therefore therefore mice
that are active during night they have
to be active sometime active during
night and inactive during day will be
selected for will be
selected for less likely to be less
likely to be hunted I guess you could
say and more likely to reproduce more
likely to reproduce reproduce and we are
done